hey everyone its Johanna here one of the
most common questions I received is how
do I get rid of my belly fat well I came
across this article in ideas fitness
journal which basically explains the
methods behind getting rid of that
stubborn belly fat it is a very detailed
article and so I am going to try my best
to provide you with as much information
as possible
so let's first start by understanding
what makes our belly fat there are three
layers to recognize first visceral belly
fat which is also known as the deep fat
this lies around the organs under the
abdominal muscles and can't be pinched
second superficial subcutaneous belly
fat which hangs over the waistline and
this can be pinched third deep
subcutaneous belly fat a hybrid of both
in this video we will be focusing on the
first two fats let's get to know them
the visceral belly fat is rich in beta
receptors it has high blood supply and
it is easier to burn the superficial
subcutaneous belly fat is rich in alpha
receptors has lower blood supply and it
is harder to burn this is the fat most
of us are concerned about because we can
visually see it hanging over our waste
line there are two enzymes which are
responsible for holding on to fat and
also burning it they are first
lipoprotein lipase LPL this enzyme is
responsible for fat storage second
hormone sensitive lipase HSL this enzyme
is involved in fat release which is what
we want so to be valid that it is not
just about creating calorie deficit it
is a combination of calorie deficit with
hormone balance the main hormones that
impact LPL activity are your insulin and
your cortisol so to simply put insulin
cortisol equals belly fat bullies the
hottest insulin causes belly fat when it
comes to the brain muscles and liver you
want the body to be insulin sensitive
and not resistance being insulin
resistance in these areas make a person
unable to burn fat and sugar or to feel
satisfied after eating this is why many
overweight people who are instantly
resistant in these tissues tend to
overeat because they are hungry all the
time
how does cortisol causes belly fat well
excess cortisol in our body can drive us
to eat more of the wrong foods more
often which means higher daily calorie
intake and fat gain this also causes
small immature fat cells to become
larger matured fat cells which is not a
good thing
when you are trying to burn belly fat in
order to burn fat we want to make sure
that these hormones are well balanced in
our body let's just start by making it
clear that diets don't work
dieting makes belly fat fatter the
common eat less exercise more approach
it's only a short-term success
this approach accomplishes the calorie
deficit but makes the hormone balance
worse
remember to burn belly fat equals
calorie deficit plus balance hormones
just think of insulin as a starch and
sugar hormone and cortisol as a sleep
and stress hormone I am sure you have
heard about the low carb and high
protein approach to reduce belly fat
this would work however a diet too low
in carbs which can cause low blood sugar
stresses of the body and raises cortisol
levels hence you do not want a diet too
low in carbs instead choosing the right
cups which are lower in glycemic load
can help with benefits and also to
reduce weight gain overall to apply this
think of a combination of protein and
vegetables as they help to suppress
hunger with minimal insulin production
this results in fewer calories consumed
and a good hormone balance please visit
the
link below for a comprehensive list of
glycemic load in foods as for dealing
with the cortisol hormone sleep and
stress management is essential in for a
good seven to eight hours of sleep every
night and practicing medication upcoming
exercises will help as well you need to
give time back to yourself mentally and
physically so to sum up when dealing
with visceral belly fat the deep fat
which has better blood flow and easier
to burn exercising stress management and
reducing cups in moderation will help it
is important to know that even if your
thing you can still have too much
visceral fat this comes down to your
genes and your lifestyle especially how
active you are visceral that likes
inactivity even if you do watch over
your diet and maintain a sleep figure
but do not exercise you are more likely
to have too much a visceral fat and this
can cause serious health problems the
key is to be active no matter what size
you are when it comes to building
subcutaneous belly fat the love handles
fat which is the subtle fat as it has
lower blood flow exercising on its own
it's not enough
reducing cops intake to low level is
usually the major focus when addressing
this matter hence the low carbs high
protein model would work so how or what
should you eat we have spoken about how
the traditional method of eat less
exercise more won't work there are two
methods to burn belly fat first it last
exercise less approach second eat more
exercise more approach both these
methods generate low calorie intake and
naturally reduce starch intake in a way
that provides enough fill to keep hunger
energy and cravings stable but not
enough to slow fat loss for the eat less
exercise less approach let's take a look
at the three to one plan 3 stands for
three meals per day two means two of
those meals should be mostly protein and
fiber with
as starch 1 means 1 mill in a day should
have heavier starch this meal is best
consumed as your post-workout meal to
visualize this on a plate three parts
should be vegetables two parts protein
and one part starch you can also think
of this in terms of bytes for every
three bites of vegetables you have two
bytes of protein and one byte of starch
this three-two-one approach works well
for those of you who are not heavy
exercises I would say if you train three
times or less in a week or you perform
gentle light exercises as for the eat
more exercise more approach let's take a
look at the three to two plan this plan
is for those of you who exercise
regularly three stands for three meals
per day two means two snacks per day
another two means you should double the
starch intake in one of them meal a day
again go for your post-workout meal to
visualize this on a plate or as bites
the meals and snacks should be half
vegetables quarter protein and quite a
starch so how do you know if you are
successful in your plan to reduce belly
fat
well again you will need to check both
calorie deficit and hormone balance for
hormone balance on a scale of 1 to 10 10
being high and 1 being low assess number
1 your hunger and cravings it should be
less than 5 second your energy level it
should be more than 6 do this assessment
at the end of each week and if your
hunger and cravings are less than 5 with
your energy level more than 6 then your
hormone balance is good the next step is
to assess our body shape using the
waist-to-hip ratio so take your waist
measurement the smallest part and divide
it with a hip measurement the widest
part for women this ratio should be
about 0.7 for men the optimal number is
0.77 always keep it below 0.8 for a
healthy waist line if it's going up to
its 0.8 or if it hasn't changed at all
then you want
look back at your food intake exercise
plan and hormone balance which one of
these are you not approaching the right
way again remember that to be belly fat
it is a combination of calorie deficit
with hormone balance not one or the
other the key to beating belly fat
include a higher protein diet
lower cups choosing the right cards
along with stress management techniques
I hope this video has helped you out to
understand the causes of belly fat and
steps to burn it all the best for new
fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
you